-Our first guest tonight
is a United States Senator
from Vermont.
Please welcome back to the show,
our friend
Senator Bernie Sanders.
Hello, Senator!
-How are you, Seth?
-Good.
You know, we last spoke
right before the election,
and now here we are in the
first full day of the Biden era.
How are you feeling?
-I am feeling great.
I -- I was almost in te--
I was at
the inauguration yesterday,
and I was in tears
seeing the new President
getting sworn in and the old
president leaving Washington.
-It will not surprise you
to know that I was aware
you were at the inauguration.
[ Both laugh ]
-I heard about that.
-Yeah.
I would say, you know,
outside of Amanda,
the inaugural poet
who was incredible,
you were sort of one of
the stars of the inauguration.
Were you aware that this photo
was immediately --
sort of became
the meme of the day?
-Not at all.
I was just sitting there,
trying to keep warm,
trying to pay attention
to what was going on.
-I appreciate that you're
not a politician who uses memes,
but you became one.
I mean, do you --
Does your staff
show them to you?
Here you are with
the "Sex and the City" girls.
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah, I've seen them.
I've seen them.
[ Laughter ]
-The other question --
-What was really nice, Seth,
is the woman
who made the mittens
lives in Essex Junction,
Vermont.
She is a schoolteacher.
And a very, very nice person.
And she has been
somewhat overwhelmed
by the kind of attention that
is being shown to her mittens.
-You know, she struck me
as the kind of supporter
who would make
Bernie Sanders mittens
because I read her saying that a
lot of people have reached out
asking for the mittens
and she basically said,
"Look, I work.
I'm a mother.
I don't have time
to make you mittens."
And I thought
that is very in line
with what I expect of you,
as well -- all business.
And I promise --
I promise to get
to a substantive
discussion here.
I don't want to waste all
the time talking about memes.
But the other question,
of course, is,
people were asking
what you were carrying.
What was your manila envelope?
-I'd love to tell you, Seth.
It's top-secret.
[ Laughter ]
-You know what?
I appreciate it.
I appreciate your honesty.
You know,
I think one of the things
we've talked about in the past
is that you obviously
are more progressive
than the President,
but you're
a longtime friend of his.
Are you encouraged thus far
by how you're collaborating,
how you're working together?
-I think the President
is off to a very good start.
And what I liked about
his inaugural remarks
and the general tone
of his administration
is he recognizes
that this country faces
a set of unprecedented crises,
from the pandemic
to the economy, to the very
threats against democracy,
to climate change,
to income and wealth inequality.
I think he understands that.
And I think if we can give him
the support that he needs
in Congress, he can, in fact,
be an extremely
progressive president
addressing the crises
facing working families.
-You've talked in the past about
reaching out to Trump voters
who felt they were left behind
by this economy.
What we saw on January 6th,
I think it's becoming
more and more clear
those were not people
that were driven by economic
anxiety who stormed the Capitol.
Is there a way to,
as a Democratic Party,
reach out to those people,
or do you have to just accept
there is never going to be
middle ground with people
who make choices like that?
-I think
the latter point is correct.
I mean,
those are fanatical people
who do not believe in democracy,
who are in many,
many cases white supremacists.
I'm not quite sure
how you can reach out to them.
But I think that there are
tens of millions of other people
who voted for Trump
who are hurting economically,
who are worried about
the future for their kids,
who are worried
about the opioid epidemic
that is hitting
their communities,
who are worried
that they do not have
the kind of
decent-paying jobs they need,
the healthcare they need,
the educational opportunities
their family needs.
And I think we can
reach out to those people.
You know,
what Trump tried to do,
spent four years
trying to divide us up
based on the color of our skin,
where we were born,
our sexual orientation,
our religion.
And our job is to try
to do the best we can
in bringing people together
around an agenda
that works for all.
Whether you are a conservative
living in rural America
or a progressive
in New York City,
you need decent healthcare.
That's what you need.
You need a decent-paying job.
So I want to focus
on those issues
that bring people together
and that improves the quality
of life for Americans.
-President Biden made, I think,
a great effort yesterday
to send a message of unity,
and he is someone who talked
in the lead-up to the election
about how he is
the kind of politician
who has friends
on the other side of the aisle.
He wants
to work with Republicans.
Yet we're already seeing
even today that Mitch McConnell
is taking steps to limit
what the Democrats
in the Senate can do.
Do you think there is some sort
of bipartisan work
that can be done in the Senate,
or are you expecting a sort of
McConnell-inspired gridlock?
-Look, I think
we should do our best
to reach out to Republicans
who represent communities
that are suffering terribly,
in terms of unemployment,
lack of healthcare,
and other very serious problems.
But I don't think our reaching
out should go on indefinitely.
This country today is hurting,
and people are hurting
really, really badly.
We're looking at people,
people who cannot
feed their kids, literally,
who are worried about
being evicted,
can't afford to go to the doctor
even when they are sick.
We have got to move
and move quickly.
So I think we should
reach out to Republicans.
If they choose not
to come on board,
which I suspect
will probably be the case,
we have the majority,
we should use that majority
in a very aggressive way.
Now, I'm gonna be chairman
of the Budget Committee,
which handles what we call
reconciliation,
and that is a Senate process
by which you can pass
not all kinds of legislation
but a whole lot
of very important legislation
with a majority vote,
not 60 votes.
And it is my view we should
make sure that we address
the needs of the American people
in that reconciliation bill,
and if we pass it with 51 votes,
we'll pass it with 51 votes.
-One of the questions that is
being asked of a lot of people
in the Senate right now,
especially with all
that President Biden
wants to accomplish quickly
due to the fact
that we are facing
the multitude of problems
you mentioned, is do we also --
or, should I say, will
impeachment be a distraction?
Do you think, moving forward,
that, one,
the Senate can balance
both getting things done
and an impeachment,
and, two, is the impeachment,
in your mind, an important thing
to move forward with?
-Well, I think both.
I mean, I think it will be
an impediment to some degree,
but I think it's something
that has to be done.
And I'll tell you why, Seth.
History must record
that this Congress made it clear
that no President can incite
his followers into insurrection,
that that is an outrageous act.
That is an attack on
the Democratic foundations
on which this country is built,
and he must be impeached.
Having said that,
there are so many problems
facing this country
that I want to see
this impeachment process
move forward.
I want to see him convicted
as quickly as possible.
We have got to show
the American people
that we can walk and chew
bubble gum at the same time.
We don't have the time to spend
weeks and months on impeachment.
People are hungry
in America today.
They're facing eviction.
They have no income.
They're worried
about the future.
We've got climate change
out there.
We got 90 million people
uninsured or underinsured.
We have got to move aggressively
to protect the American people,
and we can go forward
simultaneously
on all of these issues
if we're prepared to roll up
our sleeves and get to work.
-Well, I really appreciate
you being here.
I do want to close with my --
I think this is my favorite one
because I just don't think
you would listen
to Forrest Gump that long.
I think you would get up
and leave that bench.
[ Both laugh ]
Hey, thank you, so much.
We'll see you soon.
I really appreciate it.